[Music]
you've found Leonardo da Vinci's secret
vault secured by a series of combination
locks fortunately your treasure map has
three codes 1 2 1 0 3 2 1 1 0 0 0 and
hmm the last one appears to be missing
looks like you're gonna have to figure
it out on your own
there's something those first two
numbers have in common they're what's
called autobiographical numbers this is
a special type of number whose structure
describes itself each of an
autobiographical numbers digits
indicates how many times the digit
corresponding to that position occurs
within the number the first digit
indicates the quantity of zeros the
second digit indicates the number of
ones the third digit the number of twos
and so on until the end the last lock
takes a ten digit number and it just so
happens that there is exactly one ten
digit autobiographical number what is it
blindly trying different combinations
would take forever so let's analyze the
autobiographical numbers we already have
to see what kinds of patterns we can
find by adding all the digits in 1 2 1 0
together we get for the total number of
digits this makes sense since each
individual digit tells us the number of
times a specific digit occurs within the
total so the digits in our 10 digit
autobiographical number must add up to
10 this tells us another important thing
the number can't have too many large
digits for example if it included a 6
and a 7 and some digit would have to
appear 6 times and another digit 7 times
making more than 10 digits we can
conclude that there can be no more than
one digit greater than five in the
entire sequence so out of the four
digits 6 7 8 & 9 only 1 if any will make
the cut and there will be zeros in the
positions corresponding to the numbers
that aren't used so now we know that our
number must contain at least 3 zeros
which also means that the leading digit
must be 3 or greater
now while this first digit counts the
number of zeros every digit after it
counts how many times a particular
non-zero digit occurs if we add together
all the digits besides the first one and
remember zeros don't increase the sum we
get a count of how many nonzero digits
appear in the sequence including that
leading digit for example if we try this
with the first code we get two plus one
equals three digits now if we subtract
one we have a count of how many nonzero
digits there are after the first digit
two in our example why go through all
that well we now know something
important the total quantity of nonzero
digits that occur after the first digit
is equal to the sum of these digits
minus 1 and how can you get a
distribution where the sum is exactly
one greater than the number of nonzero
of integers being added together the
only way is for one of the add-ins to be
a two and the rest ones how many ones
turns out there can only be two anymore
would require additional digits like
three or four to count them so now we
have the leading digit of three or
greater counting the zeros a two
counting the ones and two ones one to
count the twos and another to count the
leading digit and speaking of that it's
time to find out what the leading digit
is since we know that the two and the
double ones have a sum of four we can
subtract that from ten to get six now
it's just a matter of putting them all
in place six zeroes two ones one two
zero three zero fours
0 5 s 1 6 0 7 s 0 eights and 0 9 s the
saf swings open and inside you find da
Vinci's long-lost autobiography for
today's bonus riddle here's what we'd
like you to do find all of the
autobiographical numbers if you're not
sure where to start
our partners at brilliant org have
created an exploration to help you
brilliant can show you how to solve new
and unfamiliar problems by using
critical reasoning skills they provide
frameworks to think about problems and
understand how concepts relate to each
other if you're interested in improving
your critical reasoning skills
the first 833 of you who visit brilliant
org slash ted-ed
will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription